welcome to this video playing chess
burger just blogger from Brazil let's
see himself probably took a mobile
should i do something else besides my
usual Samish f3m recently got a couple
of outings in them candidates tournament
with some success it has some
similarities of course to the sameish
sometimes even it's a transposition Jack
c6 yeah that's an interesting line
actually champion by them well known
grandmaster Rosenthal is how is this
plate actually for white interesting
blacks ideas to play b6 Bishop a6 later
and he wants to take with the sea
palling case of me capturing on d5 I
don't know what for III mmm can I do
something crazy here i think i had this
on the body once let's do that come on
let's do something crazy it takes a
recapture Knight takes Queen g-form
should be quite ok I believe yes it's
this actually I had to expect that that
the question is what exactly is this
position now taking is horrible I
probably need to play Knight f3 maybe
I'm just terribly overextended this is
possible of course
yeah a simple question is what what
happens if he takes only form and well
maybe I can play Bishop d3 simply I came
Knight c3 is probably okay hmm 94 yeah
94-95 does probably queen age form
that's not healthy some Knightly form
maybe maybe Queenie too now this looks
am a tad shaky before was it may be a
bit loose okay another another way to go
taking on c3 while still keeping the
thread of life against them we form you
cannot take on e5 with the night
unfortunately bishop d2 is going to play
94 but maybe bishop maybe I can do that
there should be 2 94 95 but there is
such a short castles probably hmm okay
hey cannot clear not clear at all to me
I need to play move them not to lose on
time yeah i gue 95 I'm not very well
developed this is a really a cause for
concern 95 castles Bishop d3 texting
they have okay let's um let's see Castle
special be okay just takes okay now
Bishop d3 and short castles or is Bishop
d3 f6 an issue i can actually castle on
f6 it takes bishop age seven should be
good for white okay
hmm yeah just retreating I guess check
yeah this is a slight problem
okay so its sequel material i have this
slight weakness on the queenside i don't
know a slight Jim I don't think it's
terrible this formation at least I've
got active pieces but I'm also probably
not better okay well this I don't don't
mind getting the night back to e5 or
some wow
I can i really just take it keep it
check keep it simple yeah the king is a
bit bit open but I don't see what he
should what you can do
in fact it's what I'm trying to do is to
get to an end game where my king is
actually actively placed while he takes
yes some time to invest with that yeah
not sure maybe you should just go to
Essex not really sure that yeah that
fancy moves get him anywhere going to g5
so I need to stay here if I exchange a
bit text a groupie one it's not really
helping but the Queen on g5 is a problem
you might threaten to take him check
Jim I haven't really found a good
solution it's even 90 for him yeah maybe
I should have played c5 actually c5
would have been interesting blend the
fifth-ranked Joe what my king I don't
think that the King possession was a
problem really maybe I'm too optimistic
but it feels so okay to me okay Majesty
for maybe there's Queen age to checkmate
no that's funny okay oh wow yeah maybe
it's already a bit a bit trickier with
with the king I mean around here I
cannot really ignite the route d8 is
something I cannot believe in but maybe
taking is wrong I thought you should
just retreat the bishop this is maybe
not a good idea
yeah yeah yeahs 90s g4s a better idea my
problem actually was shattered I was
thought chat round here looky eight was
already a not a happy move I thought
that I could actually trade the rooks
and get to an end game where have some
ideas to to play on the queenside but it
is not happening chuckling and I just
need to do after 95 worked yet I just
need to play a normal move like that
because this is really a strong piece I
could I could just keep it like that and
maybe even go to g1 if if I need to in
the final position I'm in right before
that I found this funny itself yet mate
on in this position I'm already worse
it's a bit tricky to keep them the
weakness is defended yeah Luke yet
already as mentioned wasn't really ideal
but sadly i didn't find to find anything
decent here check now the computer wants
to play king of to know maybe I tried 83
to give some protection I didn't want to
give go back simply maybe that's what I
need to do yeah it's not it's nothing
great nothing great relief may be a it's
a it's yeah I'm trying worse in a way
but not clear how much it is yeah what I
run into a cell mate ok thanks for
watching